this movie is called a boss baby and I'm
going to introduce a couple of
producer-director and then a very
special cast member who came all the way
down here to say hi so let's welcome to
the stage director Tom McGrath producer
Ramsay Nadeau and boss baby himself a
mr. Alec Baldwin
welcome thank you guys very much for
being here thanks for having me oh is
this your first comic-con alec baldwin
this is my first comic watch that is
very please don't eat me don't eat me
translation each Alec Baldwin so quickly
before we show some footage do you want
to tell some folks about boss baby and
then we'll throw the footage and then
we'll ask some questions yeah this is
great to take the opportunity because we
have a test audience of about four
thousand plus yeah and we haven't shown
this footage to anyone and we thought
we'd take the opportunity to show it to
you and it's a movie coming out called
boss baby based off a book by Marla
Frazee
about a baby who wears a suit and it's a
metaphor for when a baby comes into a
parent's life it's the boss and it
orders everyone around we took this and
turned it into a movie and centered it
on these two brothers one portrayed by
Alec and one by a seven and a half year
old Tim Templeton who's an only child
and loves it and then one day gets a
baby brother and who's no ordinary baby
brother which is of course Alec and so
just to set up this first clip we wanted
to show you the baby is delivered but
he's delivered in a taxi and he walks up
to the house and turns this kid's life
upside down and then usually delivered
you mean he arrives in a taxi delivered
arrives right he's not delivered as and
he like comes out of the womb in a taxi
they pull up in a shocking turn an
animated graphic on earth scene spoiler
what Tom meant was he pulls up in a taxi
yes he pulls up in a taxi and one night
when the kids awake and he hears some
strange murmuring coming from the
nursery and this is when he finds out
the baby can talk what was the sort of
the origin story to get this from the
book to turning into a movie all I had
to say was it's a baby in a suit voice
by Alec Baldwin quite honestly and it
got a green language what you really
said was I wonder what Alec was like as
a baby yeah yeah true uh well you know
uh it started from this children's book
and I kind of got together with Michael
McCullers who wrote the Austin Powers
movies with Mike Myers and we kind of
did a pitch and elongated pitch on you
know this sibling rivalry story which is
very personal to me because I had a
brother who's two years older than me I
was the boss baby in my family
and I tortured him and you know we were
very competitive and you know brothers
is an interesting relationship I'm sure
with sisters too were you where you you
know you fight and and you you know we
had a tumultuous kind of upbringing I
know Alec you have brothers and and
especially in your teenage years and
then after you get past that it either
makes you grow stronger or separate you
in our case it made us grow stronger and
he I love him more than anything else on
the planet you know and so this is kind
of a love letter for me to my brother
and a 50-year apology in the making
about these you know two brothers that
hate each other at first but then grow
to depend on each other and that was
kind of the pitch from the from the
movie and that's how we got it off the
ground how did they how'd you get on
board Alec I had done Madagascar 2 with
DreamWorks and with Jeffrey and then I
did rise of the Guardians with them as
well and rise of the Guardians I'm
kidding
the know I had a lot of fun doing them
with these folks and with Tom and they
came to me to do a boss baby and I
really loved working with these guys and
I love how it changes and grows over
time we record this I think we do the
voices for this and the animation for
was it about 12 13 years it takes to
make that started now where we started
this I was in my 40s when we started
yeah and my voice has changed a lot
since we first started it's been a but
computers can fix all that
but the but we do we do it and it's
great I love working with them and I
watch this and I realized the voice
contribution is just one little thing
the animation you can see is just
incredible they did an amazing job
welcome about Alec just to say you know
we did work together on Matt - and the
thing about Alec is he gives you two
lines to everyone that's written and I
just remember how much he improvised
stuff we couldn't use in the movie
better you played a lion who wanted to
rule the roost and all the other animals
and you just come up with stuff like
let's drain the watering hole so I could
build my Presidential Library in these
kinds of lines and uh and it was just
hours of material that was great it was
I always and at least in my mind was
like Alec needs to star in his own
animated movie and when we came to
casting with Jeffrey Katzenberg we kind
of both looked at each other at the same
time and said Alec you know and and we
did a baby test with some lines from
Glengarry Glen Ross haha
with a little baby that I had Megamind
and all I had to do is show that to
anybody and it just cracked him up the
baby so lucky for closers yeah uh-oh is
he pooping I think we say I always be
pooping and so it's great to have this
opportunity finally you know have Alec
as the star of a movie I hope you
release that footage by the way just as
a fun extra thing like what I hope not
there's some language issues maybe but
uh Ramsey what can you tell us about the
rest of the cast because they saw the
list and it's well we're so lucky
um steve buscemi is joining as the
villain yep
he plays Francis II Francis who is a
maniacal executive and his voice has
such range you know he he's a commanding
adult but he can really turn up this
pouting petulant baby inside and then we
have Lisa Kudrow and Jimmy Kimmel
joining his mom and dad yep very
exciting and you know they're both warm
parents you know Lisa is you know you
know she commands the she she she knows
how to manage the house manage the
boardroom and she knows how to you know
throw down the hammer like moms do and
dad is this warm
like loving father with a hint of deer
in the headlights which is hilarious
so did I read Pat is patton oswalt in
the cast as well is clear oh shoot well
I I mean um nothing I just wanted to
mention that that we hate the kid that
you heard is miles Bakshi and he's the
grandson of Ralph Bakshi and Ralph had
given me my first job in animation in
the late 80s and thought I could return
the favor giving him his grandson the
first nod I stood in line at WonderCon
to get a wizard sell signed by Ralph
Bakshi that's amazing you may show up um
Alec are you one of six kids kids six
six so what can you tell us about what's
the Baldwin's sibling rivalry all about
well I like to say to myself I'm here
and they're not oddly enough one of my
brother's is at the Republican
convention as a supporter of Trump
that's okay and my other brother was
there protesting Trump oh it's really
weird my two brothers are there on
opposite sides of this political
spectrum and I'm here wearing a diaper
and telling people what to do I've
always said there's a Baldwin for every
occasion like any occasion really is a
bizarre how does what did did you kind
of have the idea like do you kind of
knew right away what you want to do with
the character - did it evolve over time
well I always you know a lot of times I
do these films and they want you to play
these characters where you're like
straightening everybody out you know I
mean you're very tough characters and
you know the older I get now and I've
got little kids I've got two little kids
of my own and the third one coming in a
month it's like yeah if you say so it's
I'm up to my chin and little children
now it's crazy and so for me it's like
I'd rather just be in a pool with my
kids are reading a book under a tree or
something in the summertime and
you know in my life but you have to be
that guy you have to kind of channel
that guy so I meet with Tom and Ramsay
and I drink like ten espressos and drive
them completely up the wall with all my
improving and everything but it's fun I
mean I really feel like you know you got
a job to do we need to play that kind of
very forceful character and but when you
see the movie you'll see I don't want to
say anything but you'll see the arc of
the character and how it changes over
time
excellent Tom how are you so with a
movie like this obviously there's you
know you get a lot of jokes you get a
lot of improvisation but obviously it's
important to make sure that you keep the
film grounded and and have heart to it
so how do you how do you keep the film
human and balance out the comedy
elements well you always hit it with the
personal story you know like for me the
attachment is my relationship with my
brother and it any good comedy always
has to have a spine to it you know and a
solid arc to it I think like hopefully
if we do our job right people will
hopefully feel something at the end of
this movie even though it's that a lot
of comedy wrapped around its shell
because it's it's pretty Universal a
relationships with either our brothers
or sisters our parents or a boss that
you know we have issues with so
hopefully this will touch a lot of
heartstrings and they say that comedy is
the doorway to the heart and Alex or
Alec brings both I think pretty clearly
in this movie hopefully and we'll see
about that
excellent and then last I just want to
talk about the look of the movie - it
looks very specific yeah you know I
think yeah when I was a kid and growing
up with animation you know an old you go
to the theater and go to see a Disney
movie like lady in the [ __ ] or Peter
Pan or and they transported you to a
magical world and I was I came in on the
cusp of you know from 2d I learned 2d
into 3d was kind of changing and
everyone was striving for realism in
their movies and so they you know
they're putting fluorescent lighting in
an in an animated film just because they
feels more real and and on this film we
really wanted to go the other way and
bring back kind of that magic of an
animated movie that I remember from the
60s and 70s and that sort of thing so
having a kids imagination of seven half
year old imagination we're taking a lot
of opportunities to do a heightened
reality which are more like
Jones or Maurice noble or J Ward if you
know these names were kind of pioneers
and really took the medium to a more
fantastic place so we're trying to go
back to our roots in a way instead of
trying to make push the realism is make
it more really a cartoon or what we
loved about animation excellent anything
you want I just want to add that you
know when Tom mentions this because we
would talk about this you know when I
was a kid you know cartoons were of a
certain style and so forth in a certain
complexity and in college once we had a
speaker's bureau aware I would book
speakers to come to my college and we
had Mel Blanc come and it was just
really this amazing thrill to just
driving him from the airport we went to
pick him up at the airport and we didn't
pressure him to do any of his stuff
because he saved it for the show but you
know I grew up in a world where there
was that kind of clever lines that
they'd have invented children's thing
you know Bugs Bunny sing you know every
little breeze seems to whisper Louise
you know all those crazy songs they had
Bugs Bunny sing from movies and but for
now when you do these films now what's
great for me is that these are the best
people in the business you know there's
a lot of good animation companies out
there right now and when they ask you to
come and do something you know obviously
there's Pixar and other companies like
that but it's been a great pleasure for
me to work with these people and to be
able to be a part of a project with the
people that are like right at the top of
the business and you see this animation
it's just extraordinary to me excellent
yeah I mean animation I think is I think
people yeah oh yeah you can you shut
applaud that should applaud
extraordinary things animation really is
a culmination of so many great pieces of
art coming together between you know
voice acting you just you essentially
just have to use characterizations of
your voice and then you have to form a
relationship to create that in music and
everything else what is just kind of
going down the line as we wrap this up
what's your favorite part of the process
I think working well there's 400 people
that work on one of these films and it
starts with working with the writer and
then working with Alec and then the
animators are also actors and
and we have about sixty on a movie
usually by the end of the day and and
just working with artists is the great
joining because it really is about the
process it's like any probably band that
plays a song over and over and you're
probably sick of the song but people
hopefully will love it so the joy is in
the process of working with all these
creative people because by time the
movies out I've seen it ten thousand
times and I take the joy in in making it
as opposed to you know waiting for it to
you know be a hit or miss or whatever so
it's really it's really playing into the
now of making a film with great artists
excellent what about your rims making
animated movies takes a long time and
it's a very collaborative iterative
process and that the my favorite part is
definitely the collaboration you know
with with I would echo what what Tom
sent with the writers with the story
artists with the actors you know you
know but it's definitely the
collaboration I look what about you when
Katzenberg calls you and tells you he
likes the screening that he just saw
it's always a good moment excellent boss
baby comes out March 31st all right 2017
so thanks so much for being here
you
you